please welcome the hilarious robin seedy
[Applause]
you know just a little sparkly thing i
mean it is everywhere do you like it
okay it's like a little elvis a little
vegas
and when do we not need a little elvis
we all need some joy you know i've been
old elvis i've been young elvis
how are you i am so good and i'm so glad
that we're finally here together we are
such
uber fans of yours over here and also
the beautiful incredible show that you
created
i mean and it gets taken seriously which
i really appreciate uh especially for
comedy yeah which is usually you know
not kind of written off yeah no we have
been so lucky our editors won an emmy
last year
[Applause]
and it's just so cool because they're
it's all women of color who are editing
the show it's history in the making so
everything we do is not only fun and
full of joy but it's also opening the
door for so many people you know who
want to do this too so it's exciting so
good to the show i was like binging it
and it was giving me life because
i always say it comedy is my medicine
yeah for sure especially in these past
few years like we didn't know in 2019
when we were making the show
that we were going to we were doing a
fake storyline about the end of the
world about the four women on the show
living at the end of the world and then
like 10 months later it was the end of
the world and we were like it was four
women trapped in a house who could not
leave oh my god
and literally we've been exploring that
storyline for three seasons so this
season you will get answers to how it
was the end of the world and why okay
that is new information that is just for
you well
yeah
now i'm looking at this outfit oh this
whole thing i'm going wait there was a
moment where i think you talked about
how drake might be possibly tapping your
style yeah yeah yeah that's my character
chris for sure my character chris is a
guy that has like a beard and cornrows
yeah there he is so
i mean you see it look at the way we're
holding our phones it's like literally
he is copying me this was two years ago
that was like a month ago so
you guys see it right i mean you guys
see it he's copying me okay also i i not
a good looking man like that's pretty
amazing i was just about to go there i'm
not kidding yeah you are hot
so much i get a lot more love as a dude
than i do as a woman it's weird i don't
feel bad for me it's all fine i'll take
all of it
okay so may i ask who you are named
after robin williams
yeah
i know
i know oh
i know
so my dad was is is a massive fan of
comedy and he was just a massive robin
williams fan as everyone with any
intelligence is and it's so beautiful
that like that is your entry point into
the world of your parents again a little
crystal ball happening in your family
listen i am nothing like the great robin
williams and our comedy is very
different but i think that it was
permission for me to explore that and it
was permission for me to not have those
boundaries and like when we would watch
tv i would mimic the news like they
would be like tonight at five and i'd be
like tonight if i'm like as a little kid
and and they would be like they would
laugh and they would go what is that do
that again and they would just encourage
it you know and their only rule was you
have to finish college so i finished
college and then went to second city and
that was the rest but you know they're
teachers well my mom is in politics now
she's in the house of representatives in
iowa
which is amazing
i know i know
i know first black woman in her district
she's going into her eighth term she's
amazing yeah she's incredible
she's incredible um so she's you know
i'm making a sketch oh she's like i pass
marriage equality i'm like great good
for you
uh okay so you have a feature film in
the works yes uh what is going on there
okay it's at amazon it's called killing
it it's a zombie comedy that shawn of
the dead meets girls trip like a zombie
yes
like shot of the dead like zombieland
like any of those great movies so it's
four black women who got uh expelled
from spelman uh when they were in their
senior year and they go back after 10 15
years to go to their homecoming to
avenge their tarnished reputations but
they're kind of losers and on the way to
homecoming atlanta gets taken over by
zombies and they have to save themselves
and save the world
um but they're not good at it so i'm
really excited about it you never get to
see like black women doing like zombie
horror like comedy you know so i'm
really excited
[Applause]
[Music]
you